[Music]
let's go to nicole in birmingham hey
nicole what's up
hey how are you doing i'm good how are
you
good
what's up how can i help so i was just
my question was um how do i
have a relationship relationship with my
dad if my mom
won't let me
so a little bit of back story to that
hold on hold on how old are you i'm 21.
mom doesn't get a vote mom doesn't get a
vote i know i don't care whatever you're
about to say i don't care
mom doesn't get a vote
it's more of i don't want to hurt her
feelings
type thing she is choosing to have her
feelings hurt if you choose to love your
dad
yes
and that's a choice that you can't
manage
i know i'm cutting you off and i'm being
rude
all of your story and i want to hear it
but yes
you can't manage
the emotional dysregulation of the
adults in your life you can only manage
yours
yes sir okay don't say sir we're the
same age okay go so what's up tell me
the story um
so the back story is my parents divorced
when i was 13. i was a daddy's girl of
course
um why they divorced
i really don't know the full true story
neither one of them will tell me the
true story i think it was a little bit
of cheating on both ends okay um
and
i just never got the full story since i
was so young
well so they divorced my dad stayed
around for a while
and then a year later his family lives
in illinois so he moved off to illinois
didn't tell me just left
didn't try to make a relationship with
me or anything like that
about six years later he reached out
and uh my mom got pretty mad about it
because he didn't pay like any child
support he didn't
try to get in touch with me for six
years she was just kind of over it like
you don't need him you're fine
um and so
it's kind of an on and off for
a while now between me and him he'll try
to make a relationship and then he'll
make excuses of why he hadn't gotten in
contact with me
so that's why my mom's kind of like her
feelings are hurt type thing but of me
being 21 i'm
maybe going to get married to have kids
i want my dad in my life
i just don't know
how to do it or have the conversation
with my mom without hurting her feelings
gotcha so why do you want this guy in
your life
why do you want this guy
that abandoned
the most basic
responsibility
who figured out a way to untether
himself from one of the most important
loves of his life being his daughter
who left without saying goodbye
who didn't even bother to make sure you
had food on the table why do you want to
re and then now he's become
um kind of like a tornado dad he hops in
and then hops out and then hops in
creates a mess and then hops out
and
makes a bunch of promises and then
doesn't keep them up why do you want to
make a relationship with that guy
yeah uh and so that's what i can't
decide i've i've been back and forth
between you know what screw that guy i
don't need him i've made it this far
without him but then there's days and
like weeks at a time where i'm like dang
you know i really wish i had a
relationship with my dad
um
okay hold on those are two separate
things
so
this is hard okay
um
you have a fantasy in your life
about a father figure
that is different from what reality gave
you
because the real dad in your life sucks
he's lame
he hasn't shown up for you okay
and i would say that if he was on the
phone with me i'd say that if he was
sitting right here
yeah
everybody i don't know a human being on
the planet that doesn't have a picture
of a relationship with their dad that
they would love
and it sounds like you're chasing like
you have a picture of grandkids playing
with granddad and wrestling around and
going to the pool and learning how to
whittle and awk whatever
and
from what you've told me that fantasy
will not happen will not come true
and so in many ways your mom's right
you're setting yourself up for
heartbreak again and again and again
you're right and so it's less about him
and more about man i wish i had this
and that gap between what reality is and
what i wish i had is grief
and it doesn't sound like you've ever
exhaled and said
because that's that line i wrote it down
you don't need him that's not your line
that's your mom's line
yeah that's what a scorned lover says
i'll i'll figure out a way to feed this
kid i'll figure out a way to love this
kid and make sure she's got clothes and
gets off to the prom i'll make sure that
um she's someone read her a story at
night i don't need you
but that's not true about a little girl
and her dad because you do need him
and he left you
right
yeah and you're right about my mom she
you know
stuck by my side and made sure i had
everything that i ever needed
and would put herself in debt for me and
she has so but listen um that's not a
when a parent leaves you
that
oh i'll say this in the right way
your mom didn't go above and beyond she
did what was right
yeah you know what i'm saying it's your
dad that went below
you know what i mean
now being a single mom holding it all
together is heroic it's it's it's almost
impossible i don't even know how you do
that i literally don't know how you do
that um the friends of mine that have
been single moms they say you just don't
have another option you just figure it
out and you sleep you wake up 10 years
later and you know what i mean like it's
it's listening to them describe it is
harrowing so the effort in itself is
heroic
but when you step back and say man my
mom saved the day no your mom's supposed
to provide food and shelter for her her
daughter and your dad was supposed to be
there too and he left
yeah
and i want you to exhale
[Music]
yeah
because he left because something was
going on with him not because of you
yeah and it sounds like you are still
have this six-year-old or nine-year-old
little girl in your heart trying to
wonder what you did
and now maybe that i'm 21 and i'm gonna
have grandkids now maybe he'll
because you're still trying to fix what
happened between the two of you and you
didn't do it
he did yeah
yeah because the one thing that hurts my
feelings the most is i am his only
biological kid
and he went off to illinois and got
married and has step kids and does he'll
post you know on social media about
doing things with them and
you know for them and i'm like i'm your
only biological
child and you want nothing to do with me
like
i guess it's kind of a reminder like i'm
a reminder of my mom and so maybe that's
i don't that's not an excuse but
that may be what he's you know what he
sees when he sees me as my mom and he
don't like that i don't know
but
either way either way
like
trying to figure out figure out that
algorithm is a waste of your time
because you're a lovely person nicole
yeah and
you're worth having your dad stick
around and he didn't
now back to the original thing
i do believe with all of my heart that
people change
i've seen
people who are miserable parents
turn into good grandparents
and it takes an extraordinary amount of
forgiveness
they have to forgive themselves their
kids have to forgive them and it takes
an even more extraordinary
decision to say this isn't about us
anymore you blew that one
but you have a chance to redeem this
with my grandkids
and i'm gonna watch you like a hawk
because they're not getting hurt the way
you hurt me
but if you step up
we can we can heal this generational
mess
okay yeah because now we're playing
along we're playing 100-year game we're
playing a 200-year game now okay yeah
the chances of that happening are very
very very low
and you have to come in that
with this isn't gonna heal you
this isn't gonna fix that hole in your
heart
okay
okay
it's just not
um if he called you today and said i
screwed this up i messed up you were
beautiful and perfect and i left because
i was a mess i'm sorry i'm gonna make
this thing right
and you look up a year or two later and
he's a totally different guy which i've
heard of happening
um
you will walk around differently okay
yeah in a good way
but it won't be what healed you
it's because that little nine-year-old
girl will finally be let off the hook
for trying to solve a problem that she
didn't create
and so what i want you to do is i want
you to let that nine-year-old girl off
the hook now
okay
and if your dad comes around your dad
comes around but it's gonna be because
he chose to not because you did
something different to woo him back
okay
and
you're an adult now
and if you want to make a relationship
with him your mom has a choice
she can choose to see this as yes my
baby girl needs her dad
come hell or high water she needs her
dad
yeah
and it's gonna be painful and he hurt me
and he might hurt her but she's a
grown-up and so on and so forth or she
can act like a child and say well then
if you don't like that then i'm taking
my ball and i'm going to go home
yeah
and the temptation for you is to placate
her because well she did all these
things that moms are supposed to do and
dads are supposed to do which is feeding
clothes and make sure kids are smiling
right
and
she's the quote-unquote good parent and
so i've got to keep her happy
yeah that is not your job
her job okay it's her job to make her
life filled with joy
she can be disappointed in you she could
say man that really makes me mad because
that guy pisses me off right
she can get frustrated all those things
but you get to make the choice she
doesn't get a vote
because you're an adult okay okay she
can be have be have wisdom and be like
nope i've heard it all before and you
may find out conversations that have
been going on behind closed doors for
the last 15 years that you have no idea
yeah and um or not
or maybe she who knows who knows
here's the your homework assignment okay
you ready okay i'm ready homework
assignment number one is that i want you
to write a letter to nine-year-old
nicole
okay
and i want you to let nicole know
that dad left and it's not her fault
she didn't do anything wrong
okay
yes
will you do that
i will that can be oh definitely it can
be a one page letter it can be a ten
page letter i've written both to myself
okay okay
the second thing is is i want you to
take your mom out for breakfast or for
lunch and just say i wanna learn more
about my family what actually happened
would you talk to me about what happened
okay and now that you're an adult i want
you to have adult-sized conversations
with your mom and if she says absolutely
i will not say cool because she's
allowed to do that right and then you
are an adult and you get to respond you
can throw a temper tantrum and say but i
deserve to know
or you can say okay cool if you don't
want to invite me into that part if you
if you don't want to let me into that
part of your life and my family history
great
and you can do the same thing with your
dad
okay you can reach out to him with
boundaries and say i want to meet you
for lunch and if he doesn't show up then
he's telling you where he is right now
not what you're what's up what you're
about is that fair
that's fair yeah okay
when are you getting married
um well
i just hope i get married soon i'm in a
relationship of a year and a half gross
great is he nice
he is nice he's very nice he treats me
very well i've been listening to your
show for about probably a month now
and i just listened to the way you talk
about relationships and he does check
all a lot of the boxes so well if you
want me to give him a once-over have him
call the show and we'll uh i'll sit
kelly on them and we'll find out real
quick what this dude's made of
yes that sounds good
dude we should have that kelly as a part
of the show where could we just grill
potential mates
and i'll never say potential mate again
because they're not kangaroos but we
could like have potential like like
someone's thinking about getting married
we should just come up with like a
20-point checklist and just get after
him i meant yeah oh kelly's all in that
would be so funny an awesome part of the
show um
i i'll say it one more time for you and
for people listening
i'm really sorry that your dad missed
your life
thank you that should not have happened
and to the dads listening out there
don't miss your kids lives
don't miss your kids lives
because they're going to wake up and be
21 wondering still what they did
and then they're going to be reaching
out and saying i want to start my family
and i had this picture of what my
family's going to look like and because
you did what you did
now i've got to redo all my pictures
and i have to grieve all this stuff okay
um
you're worth being loved nicole and
prom
sit down with this cat that you're about
to marry gross and
make sure everybody's on the same page
yes if we're if we're doing this we're
doing this once and we're doing this for
life and we're going to be around for
the kids
yes is that fair
that's fair all right you are awesome
nicole thank you so so much for being
brave and thank you for the call